bonsoir à vue alors c'en est où ce
procès avec bastos heures bien sonnées
apparemment c'est réglé qui est ce qu a
gagné c'est nous ah ben on dit quoi le
morceau là authentique
enfin des médias et dit quoi que je me
marre ben toutes ces choses qui sont
dites comme par exemple en les lisant on
pourrait croire que champions que son
copain à nous tous un coin j'ai tous les
a priori de son fait tout simple
évidence vos mamans elles pensent quad
du nombre groupe ensemble
ah bon ces gènes pourraient pas du tout
masami seigner ou si c'est une
expression de la barre ça dérangeait pas
pas la première fois que tu es arrivé
chez toi tu as dis à ta mère je fais un
groupe ça s'appelait nique ta mère a
joué pas dit la première fois n'a pas
osé un vous êtes soutenus par jack lang
qui est toujours du bien de vous ouais
ouais ouais il paraît si un jour on vous
proposait de faire l'arbre de noël à
l'elysée vous iriez bonne non mais
d'abord on n'est pas soutenu par jean
claude kouassi la subvention qu'il a
offert quand on propose de l'argent être
encore plus faux pas mais je me suis
conscient mais prend way
sinon je ne connais pas personnellement
j'avais alors l'arbre de noël à l'elysée
non pour maintenant je vais pas imagine
qu'ils aient envie de faire plaisir par
les no mercy émergents ces jeunes gens
me donnent plan on reçoit on se plaît à
recevoir le paleron site de lancement il
me donne épicé vous un bon tu le gardes
ouais bon merci